wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es am ende des semesters in unserem
seminar ethik der digitalität um eine
zusammenfassung und auch um einen
ausblick wir haben sehr sehr viele
themen behandelt oben rechts ist die
playlist zum gesamten seminar drin
diejenigen unter ihnen die sich dafür
interessieren noch mal alles revue
passieren zu lassen ich möchte jetzt
heute wie gesagt ein rück begeben und
auch die leitfragen und zur seminars
nochmal rekapitulieren damit sie noch
mal sehen welche fragen wir uns
vorgenommen hatten und wir hoffen dass
wir auf alle zu sprechen kamen
vielleicht auch heute noch auf eine neue
frage zu sprechen kommen also welche
neuartigen ethischen herausforderungen
geben mir digitalisierungen her das ist
die hauptfrage die im zentrum des
seminars stand dann musste natürlich um
diese frage beantworten zu können sich
überhaupt erst mal überlegen was ist
überhaupt digitalisierung das ist jetzt
ja gar nicht so klar und auch neue
medien was sind das man spricht ja
häufig auch zunehmend digitalisierung
und neuen beetle
dann hatte man gesehen dass diese
digitalisierung und die neuen medien
sehr schnell auf den anderen begriff
verweisen nämlich auf den betrieb der
virtuellen realität und auch hier muss
man sich fragen wie viel ist virtuelle
realität ethisch verlängert
inwiefern können wir das internet und
jetzt kommt eben die übertragung der
virtuellen realität auf verschiedene
phänomene wie viel können wir das
internet als einen virtuellen
handlungsraum als metapher suchen wie es
neuerdings immer mehr in den blick gerät
bestimmen und welche regeln soll dahin
gelten was sind ihre hand wie können sie
im computer spiele mehr als nur
simulationen wie viel können wir werden
können sie ethisch problematisch sein
das betrifft natürlich wieder die frage
nach der virtuellen realität
dann das nächste große thema nach
internet computerspiele die ki natürlich
inwiefern ist einsatz und ethisch
problematisch wie sollte ethisch mit
unseren digitalen daten umgegangen
werden
worin besteht uns mit digitale identität
und digitale würde und wie fern sollen
können wir sie schützen betrifft auch
die privatsphäre thema datenschutz
worin besteht das digitale gute und
worin das digitale böse wenn man es mal
konkret jetzt anwendet und zum schluss
das bezieht sich auf die letzte sitzung
inwiefern benötigen gerne digitale
aufklärung und wie ist sie verfasst und
wie sollte sie verfasst sein das war
eine menge anfragen und wir schauen
jetzt noch mal welche fragen wie davon
beantworten oder behandeln konnten und
welche vielleicht noch offen sind
erst noch zur philosophie der neuen
medien
warum sollten wir uns philosophisch
überhaupt eine digitalisierung befassen
ist es nicht die aufgabe der informatik
die frage müssen wir uns als philosophin
den philosophen ganz nehmen
die antwort darauf lautet ganz einfach
die digitalisierung ist nicht mehr nur
für interesse für die informatik seien
sie betrifft uns alle
stichwort lebenswelt die digitalisierung
trägt alle bereiche vor ich habe hier am
armband einer uhr überall werden sie
immer mehr chips finden es gibt
untersuchungen wie viele chips sie an
sich selbst tragen oder wie viele chips
sie ihre wohnung haben das sind werden
immer mehr und man wird sie immer
weniger wahrnehmen das ist ja der punkt
es wird man mehr und sie verschwinden
immer mehr sie werden immer kleiner sie
werden immer nahtlos in unser leben
integriert diese nahtlose sich kalt der
integration digitaler technik so dass
sie gar nicht mehr als technik erscheint
wie zum beispiel dampfmaschinen die da
irgendwelche geräusche und dem feld sich
lässt mechanisch sondern die diese
reibungslos sich kite auf diese kleine
und kleinigkeit diese dynamisierung kite
und integrierbarkeit von digitalen
medien weil es eben so klein und so
flüssig ist
das zeige die digitalisierung aus wir
kommen gleich noch genauer das zu
sprechen was jetzt genau digital analog
bedeutet philipp specht das zitat hatte
ich auch schon ein paar mal gebracht
behauptet in seinem sehr lesenswerten
buch über die transformationen
digitalisierung dass das uns für eine
gewaltige zivilisatorische
herausforderung stellen wird die
digitalisierung dem stimme ich jetzt mal
zu auch wenn es immer wieder phasen gibt
wo aufgrund von energiemangel vielleicht
weniger digitalisieren betrieben wird
aber auf lange frist scheint diese
entwicklung unaufhaltsam zu sein genauso
wie die elektrifizierung
[Musik]
ja jetzt gibt es eine kritik der neue
medien wie ich auch nicht verschweigen
möchte da wo es transformation gibt da
gibt es auch immer ängste und
befürchtungen und hier etwa aus
psychologischer sich die digitale demenz
von manfred spitzer der einer der
größten deutschsprachigen kritiker der
digitalisierung ist
cyber krank also ich finde die titel
sehr originell das digitale leben
ruiniert unsere gesundheit und die
smartphone epidemie
gefahren als ich mit auf gefahren
hingewiesen vor allem eben auch auf
kinder
und diesen ganzen kritiken ist
sicherlich erstmal zuzustimmen dass jede
neuartige disruptive technologie auch
immer ihre spezifischen probleme mit
sich bringt das ist völlig klar und das
hatten wir auch in der letzten sitzung
dann mache ich oben rechts den linken in
der sitzung über digitale aufklärung
thematisiert die frage nach der
digitalen mündigkeit
digital unbändig ist jemand wenn er die
ganze zeit für solchen geräten
wie
laptops oder anderen monitoren und hier
spielekonsolen benutzt und controller in
der hand hat solche menschen überwiegend
junge menschen überwiegend auch
männliche junge menschen die verwechseln
simulation mit realität und das ist
sicherlich ein problem aber das spricht
eben jetzt nicht und das ist mein
einwand gegen spitze er spricht nicht
grundsätzlich gegen die digitalisierung
weil sich digitalisierung auch sehr
konstruktiv nutzen lässt es hängt also
immer davon ab wie man digitalisierung
einsetzt nutzen wir sie als bloßes
konsum und unterhaltungsmedium dann
können wir durchaus von cyber krank
digitale demenz und smartphone epidemie
sprechen nutzen wir hingegen die
digitalen medien kreativ im sinne einer
erzeugung virtueller realität das können
wir nämlich alles tun wir können damit
videokonferenzen machen wir können damit
das handy können wir das smartphone
können wir verwenden im sinne eines
universalwerkzeug wir können ein
höhenmesser
darunter installieren wir können damit
kommunizieren wir können arbeiten damit
also es hängt vom gebrauch ab und wenn
wir diese digitalen medien sinnvoll
sprich kreativ im sinne der
virtualisierung herkömmliche
arbeitsabläufe einsetzen dann sind sie
eben gerade keine gefahr mehr sondern
irgendwie doch ein weg unser leben zu
verbessern und das möchte ich diese
generellen etwas einseitigen kritik von
manfred spitzer entgegen erhalten
jetzt möchte ich noch mal ein bisschen
auf das verhältnis von digitalisierung
und digitalität eingehen das ist ja so
delight differenz von diesem seminar
genießen wir müssen als unterscheiden
die technische seite des verhältnis von
analog und digital das betrifft die
digitalisierung ohne das verhältnis von
digitalisierung versus digitalität das
betrifft die philosophische seit ich
möchte jetzt mal ein bisschen was zu
treten ist von analog und digital sagen
was vielleicht im laufe des semesters
etwas zu kurz kam das betrifft jetzt
natürlich nur die digitalisierung wir
haben hier zwei signale ein analoges
signal
das ist so das es wert kontinuierlich
das heißt wenn sie diese achse hier als
y achse ansehen wo der wert auf getragen
wird die t-aktie zeitachse dann sehen
sie pro zeitpunkt haben sie ja ein
schönes kontinuum es gibt keine sprünge
also diese kurve ist mathematisch
gesprochen nicht nur stetig sie können
sie durch zeichnen sind auch
differenzierter sie haben an jedem punkt
einen eindeutigen an jedem zeitpunkt an
eindeutigen
wert der gar eine eindeutige funktion ja
also stetig und differenziert man
differenzieren heißt ein kontinuum sie
können die kurve durchziehen ohne
irgendwelche ecken und kanten oder
lücken um die natur sagt man eben also
zum beispiel ein live konzert oder
natürliche geräusche wie auch immer
nehmen sie an ein live konzert ein
konzert wird gespielt ein sommerkonzert
mit klassischen instrumenten eine
violine eine op
diese töne die dann erzeugt werden die
haben dieses diese form also sind wert
kontinuierlich
wenn sie jetzt hingegen dieses konzert
aufzeichnen zum beispiel dann auf einen
digitalen tonträger wie eine cd
veröffentlichen dann wird dieses signal
so aussehen diese kurve ist auch stetig
es gibt hier keine lücken aber sie ist
nicht differenziert war nämlich an
diesen punkten hier in diesen ecken da
wird dieses signal nicht mehr
kontinuierlich soll nur noch diskret und
dieses diskrete bedeutet eben die
digitalisierung die nullen und einsen
also analoge signale sind wert
kontinuierlich die lassen sich mehr oder
weniger durchziehen und da gibt es keine
ecken und kanten wären im digital wird
alles zerlegen und einzeln und dadurch
kommen wir so kleine kanten rein es
handelt sich also so könnte man sich
fragen um eine simulation also das
digitale signal simuliert das analoge
signal mit mitteln dieser binären logik
von null und eins muss dafür aber solche
treppchen kauf nehmen dafür aber wird
dieses signal eben digitalisiert also
sieht ein digitales signal aus das ist
jetzt alles noch die technische seite
die philosophisch die quelle ist
wikipedia die philosophische seite
betrifft jetzt die frage
wie diese umwandlung also die
transformation von analogen
informationen dem kontinuum hin so
diskreten also digital information
philosophisch genau zu verstehen also
begrifflich und moralisch wie ist diese
transformation zu verstehen und jetzt
gibt es mehrere möglichkeiten wie man
das verstehen kann das betrifft jetzt
die philosophie man kann jetzt sagen die
digitalisierung simuliert nur die
analoge welt also diese eckchen und
treppchen in diesem digitalen
signal die sind nur simulationen also
man kommt da der realität nur ein
bisschen näher aber wenn sie genau
hinhören eine cd da wird eine expertin
immer sagen nein das ist nicht live das
ist nur gespielt dass es nur aus einer
cd gespielt und es gibt leute die können
das weil eben bestimmte höhere
frequenzbereiche durch die kompression
zu fahrende digitalen eben immer raus
gelassen werden es handelt sich immer um
eine simulation vielleicht auch um eine
abstraktion von dem natürlichen signal
das wäre eine interpretation hier sind
jetzt aber auf der philosophischen eben
weil in der auf der gewöhnlichen
technischen ebene interessiert das nicht
so sehr interessiert nur der zweck ist
die cd aufnahme gut ist die qualität gut
können wir erkennen können wir richtig
hören was da passieren die frage ob das
jetzt eine simulation ist oder eine
publikation bekomme ich auch gleich
darauf die interessiert uns auf der
ebene der digitalisierung nicht sofern
die qualität okay ist die menschen
kaufen die cd die qualität ist gut sie
hören richtig was darauf zu hören sein
zeugt und dann stellen sich keine wald
umfragen wir philosophien und
philosophen sollten zu meinen hier aber
er ist gerade anfangen wir sollten
darauf reflektieren handelt es sich um
eine simulation oder um eine duplikation
duplikation bedeutet die digitalisierung
führt zu einer zweiten wirklichkeit die
analoge wirklichkeit nach und nach
ersetzt also in diesem sinne könnte man
zum beispiel sagen
wir
erstellen künstliche intelligenzen auch
durch digitalisierung die digitale
technik und diese intelligenz leistung
der künste intelligenz simuliert nicht
nur obwohl es häufig der anschein hat
systems die simuliert nicht nur uns für
wirklichkeit unsere akte und
erkenntnisse sondern sie dupliziert sie
also da kommt was neu ist entspiegelt
diese frage stellt sich uns kommt mit
der digitalisierung was neues ins spiel
oder wird das bestehende analoge nur
mehr oder besser weniger oder mehr
simulieren
die frage ist nicht ganz eindeutig zu
beantworten sicherlich gibt es viele
phänomene die nur simulationen bedeutet
bei der digitalisierung aber es gibt
auch tendenzen die eben die virtuelle
realität betreffen wo wir sie
tatsächlich mit neuen wirklichkeiten zu
tun haben wo wir arbeitsabläufe durch
die digitalisierung völlig neu
strukturieren beispiel eben
videokonferenzsystem digitale lehre wäre
so ein beispiel wenn sie nicht nur
simulation ist sondern eben neue wege
eröffnet die sich durch die
digitalisierung ermöglicht also die
philosophie der digitalisierung steht
zwischen simulation und publikationen
das ist nicht ganz klar was hier bei
herauskommt und lange rede kurzer sinn
ich glaube worauf es ankommt ist auf die
duplikation wir wollen mit der
digitalisierung nicht nur simulieren
weil die simulation bedeutet ja in der
wirklichkeit ist immer noch besser wir
wollen das wäre immer noch original und
publikation
original und kopie sozusagen dann wäre
die digitale bild nur eine billige kopie
der wirklichen welt das ist eine
möglichkeit ich glaube spannender wird
es wenn man sagt die digitalisierung ist
nicht nur eine kopie der wirklichkeit
celsius eine neue wirklichkeit die
eigene gesetze eigene regeln hat und da
wird es dann spannend diese eigenen
gesetzlichen regeln philosophisch zu
bestimmen
und jetzt die schon den begriff
angeführt virtuelle realität neue medien
sind virtuelle realität virtuelle
realität müssen wir von simulationen
fiktionen emotionen strengen bescheiden
auch wenn man das häufig im alltag tun
weil wir eine 3d brille uns vorstellen
und dann gegen damit haben wir schon
soziale realität was damit er war
eigentlich gemacht wird ist ja nur eine
simulation der wirklichen welt das ist
nicht wirklich real das heißt virtuelle
realität muss damit sie realität ist
lebensweltlich kann zahl wirksam und
objektiv sein also darf nicht mehr nur
abhängig sein von einer simulierten bild
da müssen neue formen der realität ins
spiel kommen beim aber dennoch hat es
bei virtuelle realität immer auch
momente von simulationen fiktion in sich
wenn sich zum beispiel das metaversum
vorstellen indem wir interagieren dann
könnte man sagen bis zum bestimmten
punkt ist eine simulation aber auch mit
bestimmten punkt ist keine simulation
erwähnt sich eigene digitale kulturen
entwickeln die man auch zum beispiel
computer spielen sieht wo es fiktive
gegenstände gibt magische ringe die
einen virtuellen wert haben und die
nicht bloß simulation sind das heißt
virtuelle realität ist ein kreatives
phänomen das stark an unsere freiheit
appelliert und virtuelle realität das
habe jetzt so ausdrückt die bedeutet
eine anthologie der freiheit das heißt
in der virtuellen realität werden wir
frei von physischen beschränkungen weil
wir uns dadurch durch die
digitalisierung lösen könnt und neue
form der realisierung entwickeln können
ich möchte dazu jetzt ein paar weitere
beispiele im folgenden auch geben ein
weiterer punkt in unserem seminar war
das thema privatheit als philosophisches
problem warum ist das ein problem
datenschutz bedeutet dass bestimmte
informationen über eine person geschützt
werden dh die person kann selbst
entscheiden welche informationen sie
sich wann wo und wem zugänglich war
hat also ganz stark etwas mit der
autonomie zu tun niemand möchte dass er
zum bloßen gegenstand der
digitalisierung wird niemand möchte bloß
digitalisiert werden im internet oder wo
auch immer wir wollen mit bestimmt was
mit unseren informationen passiert
privatsphäre ist es wie ein raum der
intimität und individualität in dem
nicht einfach ohne weiteres eingegriffen
werden kann wenn wir jetzt aber im
internet zugänge sind sind wir immer
kennt gänsen ausgesetzt dass wir
vergeben ständig werden dass man
irgendwelche daten oder informationen
zucker abgreift science metadaten also
fragen wann ich im internet war welche
seite nicht angeschaut habt und so
weiter diese metadaten die werden immer
interessanter warum weil wir selbst zum
gegenstand ökonomischen interessen
werden das heißt die verletzung der
privatsphäre bedeute immer auch die
person zu vergeben stündlich wie
verändert sich jetzt aber die
privatsphäre wenn wir im internet
unterwegs sind
dies sind entschieden und das ist mir
ganz wichtig davon ab die wir das
internet verstehen ist das internet nur
ein konsum medium ist das internet nur
ein
spielplatz eine simulation oder ist das
internet mehr als das sondern ein
virtueller handlungsraum und ich würde
stark für das letztere argumentieren das
internet ist eine handlungsraum nicht
nur ein informationsmedium nicht nur
also ein konsum medium das heißt wir
können die ethische bedeutung des
internets nur dann angemessen bestimmen
wenn wir es als einen virtuellen
handlungsraum bestimmen bis jetzt zwei
dinge voraus zum einen virtuelle
realität muss stärker verstanden werden
als bloße simulation illusion oder
fiktion weil infektionen gelten keine
moralischen regeln zumindest nicht wie
in unsere wirklichen welt eine
simulation auch nicht ist ja nur ein
spiel ohne illusionen schon gar also
virtuelle realität mit blick auf den
virtuellen handlungsraum des internets
muss stärker verstanden werden wir
müssen auch bestimmen was rituelle
handlungen sind und das hängt natürlich
immer auch damals samt welche raum und
zeit logik sich uns hier da bietet also
wie sich zeit und raum in der virtuellen
realität sondern das verhalten sie
können sich denken ändert sich einiges
der raum in der virtuellen realität ist
kein physischer raum mehr dennoch ist es
ein raum weil es seine ausdehnung hat
der raum kann größer oder kleiner sein
wir können frei fühlen in diesen bronk
wir können uns aber auch beschränkt
führen und es hängt immer auch davon ab
wie wir in diesem virtuellen raum
interagieren
ja das finde ich ganz wichtig also raum
begriff mit blick auf virtuelle realität
dynamischer stehen abhängig vom zugeht
wenn wir uns gut verhalten im virtuellen
handlungsrahmen wenn wir informationen
teilen wenn wir dafür sorgen dass keine
fake news veröffentlicht werden kann
vergrößern wir den raum wenn wir
hingegen fällt muss streuen oder den
blasen uns aufhalten immer wieder nur
selbstbestätigung erfahren wollen dann
verkleinern wir den virtuellen handlungs
fragen wir bestimmen selbst mit als
nutzerinnen nutzer
ob wir den virtuellen handlungsraum des
internets vergrößern oder verkleinern
ja da gibt es noch eine ethik der
künstliche intelligenz der bericht auch
wichtig ist die ethik der künstlichen
intelligenz setzt auch voraus dass wir
erst philosophisch einige fragen klären
ist künstliche intelligenz ein subjekt
kann
künstliche intelligenz handeln besitzt
künstliche intelligenz internationalität
also eine geistige gerichtet auf ein
objekt
ist künstliche intelligenz augen herum
also kann könnte intelligenz
eigenständige entscheidungen treffen
handeln
diese fragen müssen wir uns stellen
bevor wir darauf zu sprechen kommen
jetzt gibt es verschiedene positionen
bezüglich von calais die gleichermaßen
problematisch sind es sollten uns um
einen these von diesen vier
problematischen position abgrenzen
einmal die ideologisierung also dass man
der meinung ist wir kommen doch gleich
darauf die ki ist das heil der menschen
das ist die zukunftsperspektive damit
werden alle probleme gelöst weil es eine
suppe intelligenz gibt die auch
moralisch vielleicht irgendwann die
menschliche existenz übersteigert dass
es diese silicon valley ideologie dann
gibt es die tendenz die ki zu
anthropomorphen also kann jetzt zu sehr
als eine menschliche person zu verstehen
ein roboter robotern menschliche
eigenschaften zuzugestehen dann der
banalisierung von k s halt ich auf eine
problematische tendenz ki als bloßes
hilfsmittel wie so ein hammer mit dem
wir nägel einschlagen können warum
trifft das nicht zu das müssen wir
besprechen und der dramatisierung der
kalli als zu bekämpfen die gefahr der
moderne zeit als ideologische
gegenposition zur ersten position also
die künstliche intelligenz nimmt uns die
ganzen arbeitsplätze weg das geht ja
noch das ist ja noch recht harmlos denn
es sind aber dahin geht an zu
befürchtungen dass die künstliche
intelligenz die weltherrschaft übernimmt
und die menschheit auslöschen möchte
weil die menschheit ja in augen der k
wie viel zu dumm ist
oder die menschheit versklavte dann
handelt es sich auch um ideologisierung
aber im sinne der dramatischen und das
halte ich auch für problematisch wir
brauchen einen mittelweg zwischen diesen
vier positionen wie könnte der jetzt
aussehen
ja das ist dieses problem das sind die
vier positionen und wie sie der
mittelweg aus wir müssen das ist meine
these
verschiedene formen von kunst
intelligenz unterscheiden und immer
drauf schauen welche chancen bieten sich
hier und ganz zentral sind dabei formen
kürzlich intelligenz im 10 euro nala
netz das ist der sogenannte konvektion
ismus dabei wird nicht von oben nach
unten gewissermaßen detektiv geschlossen
von regeln die man in den computer ein
programmiert und dann irgendwie ein
anwendungsfälle
heraus schließen lässt sondern man lernt
dabei das system lernt auf basis von den
tierischen daten gewissermaßen induktiv
also von unten nach oben ein beispiel
ist google spracherkennung autonome
fahrzeuge die werden mit ganz viel
empirischen informationen gefüttert und
können auf dieser basis dann
in der rallye muster erkennen generelle
muster heraus dann lösen und die
vorteile sind natürlich die flexibilität
und erlernen für diese kss thema lassen
sie auf ganz verschiedene situationen
anwenden und lassen sich auch immer
wieder
berichtigen korrigieren das hat ist der
lerneffekt der diese den diese systeme
erzielen können das problem ist die
ergebnisse die dieses system heraus
bringen sind wir wahrscheinlich und
nicht immer nachvollziehbar weil es so
eng vernetzt ist die
entscheidungsfindungen
anführungsstrichen die ihre systeme ist
für uns menschen aufgrund der großen
komplexität nicht mehr ohne weiteres
nachvollziehbar
ein vorteil ist wie ich schon sagte die
flexibilität das ist also der kollektion
ist muss dem ich gerade vorgestellt habe
und
einsatz noch dazu wir müssen diese
künstliche intelligenz im sinne der
neuronalen netze der kollektion ist
ischen modelle so nutzen um sie ethisch
fruchtbar zu machen dass sie
als erweiterung unserer virtuellen
realität zu verstehen sind also nicht
als einschränkung auch nicht nur als
hilfsmittel wie ein hammer künstliche
neuronale netze sind sehr flexibel die
lassen sie auf alle möglichen bereiche
anwenden und sie erleichtern uns und sie
vergrößern unsere freiheit weil sie
unsere mentalen gehalte gewissermaßen
weiterverarbeiten und äußern uns
zugleich auch mit anderen subjekten
beziehungen setzen lassen also das wäre
mein argument künstliche neuronale netze
nicht nur als hilfsmittel zu verstehen
sind als formen unsere erweiterung
unserer virtuellen realität
darüber können am ende auch noch
diskutieren dann war noch ein thema die
ethik und fiktion
von digitalen phänomenen tätig hat ist
nicht nur mit der vergangenheit und
gegenwart auch mit der möglichen zukunft
zu tun das ist auch eine wichtige
dimension der ethik der digitalität egal
es auch nicht nur mit notwendigkeit und
wirklichkeit und auch mit möglichkeit
tun was könnte das sein und wie ist das
ethisch zu bewerten
infektionen zeigen sich immerhin neue
ethische dimensionen die früher oder
später eventuell werden können deswegen
mein plädoyer
fiktionen nicht immer nur so als bloße
spielerei abzutun sind sie auch ernst zu
nehmen wir sehen dass zum beispiel
büchern wenn es um das die frage zum
beispiel gegen einen überwachungsstaat
das buch 1984 und so weiter also in der
fiktion werden häufige szenarien
antizipiert die dann irgendwann später
auch mal wirklichkeit werden und an
diesem beispiel kann man schon sehr gut
mögliche ethische szenarien in der
fantasie durchspielen
dann war noch ein wichtiges thema
roboter da habe ich aufpassen offs
roboter gesetze
abgehoben asimov ist ein
autor gewesen so mitte des 20
jahrhunderts der auch den begriff des
roboters in die fiktion eingebracht hat
also roboter darf kein menschliches
wesen wissentlich so seine these
verletzen oder durch untätigkeit
wissentlich zu lassen das einen
menschlichen lesen schaden zugefügt wird
das sind diese ob butter gesetze die
natürlich nur in der fiktion
existieren die ich aber trotzdem
spannend findet ein roboter muss dem ihm
von einem menschen gegebene befehlen
gehorchen
es sei denn ein solcher befehl würde mit
regel 1 kollidieren dass all seine
menschen leid angetan wird roboter muss
seine existenz beschützen so lange
dieser schutz nicht mit regel eins oder
zwei kollidiert also die existenz des
roboters ist immer der existenz des
menschen untergeordnet aber der roboter
hat eine zumindest relative
existenzberechtigung er hat ein existenz
interesse er muss sich selbst aufrecht
erhalten sofern damit nicht mit der
menschlichen würde kollidiert das ist
schon mal ganz ganz spannendes spannende
thema ich finde dass es aus dem buch
meine freunde die roboter
dann haben wir uns beschäftigt das war
dieses problem der ideologisierung kann
kann nicht nur von k s von der gesamten
digitalen entwicklung der mit dem thema
des transform annis muss dann mache ich
auch oben rechts den link dann zu der
entsprechenden sitzung ein
hier hatten wir von ray kurzweil das wie
ich finde sehr lesenswerte buch
singularity isnyer gelesen die
singularität ist nahe warum ist dieses
buchs spannend ich glaube deswegen weil
hier eben auch verschiedene dimensionen
mit einbezogen werden hier gibt es ganz
stark fiktionale ansätze die einen die
zukunft weisen es geht also um utopien
vielleicht zur bergung des toten eine
dystopie ist eben das gegenteil von
einer utopie da ist etwas in der zukunft
was vielleicht auch problematisch sein
könnte das wird jetzt hier noch offen
gelassen also ein sehr spannendes buch
weil es auch fiktionale
aspekte enthält die aber sehr gut mit
technischer informationen technischen
wissen unterfüttert
der untertitel wenn ich jungen strength
and biology ist sprechend wenn die
menschheit die biologie überschreitet es
geht also darum dass biologisch
natürliche
grenzen überwunden werden sollen im
sinne eines tanz humanismus und jetzt
möchte ich noch ein bisschen darauf
eingehen was darunter genau zu verstehen
also wir haben hier einen zeitstrahl die
geht bis ins jahr
2100 wir sehen wir sind jetzt ungefähr
so hier 2020 und auf der y-achse auf der
wehrte achse da gibt es die
rechenleistung auch noch per dollar und
per sekunde also es geht um die
rechenkapazität die in diesem jeweiligen
jahr erreicht wird und wir sehen das
nimmt natürlich ganz stark zu hier sehen
wir die potenzen die gehen grad zu hoch
also die die wandelnde gehen ständig
weiter hoch und sie werden extrem stark
es ist eine logarithmische
kurve und sie ist zugleich auch noch
exponentiell das heißt die kurve die
steigt immer weiter an die ist nicht nur
im jahr also aktiv mit demselben
derselben steigungs und die steigung die
nimmt zu mit jedem jahr
und irgendwann im jahr 2060 zum beispiel
da haben wir praktisch für einen dollar
pro sekunde eine rechenleistung die
allen menschlichen gehirn entspricht das
ist natürlich schon gewaltig also die
kalkulation pro sekunde für eine dollar
rechenleistung entspricht der summe
aller menschlichen gehirn im jahr 2060
es ist nicht mehr allzu lange hin das
sollten wir alle noch sofern wir dieses
alter erreichen eben erleben dürfen
zumindest nach der prognose von ray
kurzweil und das kann man sich das
natürlich weiter vorstellen irgendwann
weil dass er noch immer steiler zunimmt
irgendwann hier im jahr 2100 da ist halt
pro dollar pro sekunde die
rechenleistung so groß wie vielleicht
die von
dem tausendfachen der menschheit oder
ein vielfaches der menschheit und so
könnte man sich überlegen dass sie einen
zustand eintritt wo so viel intelligenz
gewalt so eng vernetzt ist dass es hier
zu einer neuen intelligenten form kommt
die gewissermaßen autonom wird und
unsere biologie überschreite das ist
diese spannende prognose fiktion ich
habe es jetzt mal genannt ransmann ismus
als techno geschichte warum techno
geschichte kurzweil bringt hier
verschiedene epochen einer evolution die
beginnt die kennen wir alle am anfang
mit der physik und chemie als iris
gibt's teilchen auf musikalischer ebene
dann verbinden verbinden sich teilchen
zu molekülen und dann irgendwann zu
zählen mit den erbinformationen dann
entwickelt sich neuronale gehirne dann
taucht die technologie auf und
irgendwann epoche fünf da verschwimmt
die technologie mit menschlicher
intelligenz und epoche sex geht sogar so
weit dass sich die intelligenz die
menschlich technologisch transformiert
intelligenz auf das gesamte universum
überträgt also die letztmögliche
perspektive unsere intelligenz das habe
ich jetzt eine techno geschichte genannt
man könnte es auch eine techno
technologien also hier wird eine
immanente
bewegungsrichtung angenommen von ganz
primitiven informationen bis hin zur
aller komplexesten information die sich
in das gesamte universum verbreitet und
gar nicht mehr angewiesen auf einen
biologischen körper
aus diesem buch das sie genießen ja
dann haben wir uns nach einem phänomen
zugewendet nämlich den computerspielen
das wort medium komplett einisch mitte
und bedeutet soviel wie
vermittlungsinstanz wir müssen uns also
immer auch fragen was ist eigentlich
unser medium zu verstehen sind jetzt
computerspiele nur vermittlungs
instanzen wenn wir sie so ansehen
zwischen war es vermitteln sie da
inzwischen wem
computerspiele ziehen zumindest von
medien wie viel man zeitungen und bücher
verschieden da sie nicht nur passiv
rezitiert und konsumiert sondern aktiv
gespielt werden das übersieht dieses
buch von manfred spitzer mit dem titel
digitale demenz wie ich finde schon weil
hier eben nur der konsum aspekt ins
zentrum gut dann müsste jetzt mal
genauer genommen computer spielerinnen
computerspieler befragen warum sie den
spielen überhaupt alle menschen die
spielen und hier wird man sicherlich
hören zu hören bekommen dass es hier
nicht nur um einspielen oder bespaßen
geht sind diese menschen werden
antworten das nehme ich jetzt mal an
zumindest würde ich so sagen dass sie
darin zumindest mal abschalten können
das wäre vielleicht auch sein wort
abschalten
aber wenn man sie weiter befahren würden
sie sagen ich kann dadurch neue
erfahrungen machen ich kann mich auch
weiterentwickeln
ich kann
neue dimensionen eröffnen ich kann meine
kreativität freien lauf lassen ich kann
neue strategien entwickeln ich kann mich
neu ab offen ich kann nicht vielleicht
auch noch selbst wahrnehmen und
kennenlernen durch diese spiele also es
geht letztendlich nicht nur darum dass
ich was konsumiert und sei es geht um
eine neue form von selbsterfahrung und
mehr noch selbst betätigung und
vielleicht auch selbstverwirklichung in
manchen hinsicht also ist es deutlich
mehr als nur dieser passiven konsum nur
das abschalten sondern es geht um das
spiel um die freiheit um die entwicklung
in neuen rahmenbedingungen die von
unserer alltagswelt verschieden sind
also ist es die interaktion in der
fiktion und das ist natürlich ein
faszinierendes phänomen weil wir häufig
natürlich auch romane lesen darin
künstliche fiktive welten versetzt
werden in computerspielen können wir
diese künstlichen welten selbst
bevölkern und
interaktiv beeinflussen und mitgestalten
das ist der entscheidende unterschied
also in computerspielen werden wir
selbst aktiv und wir werden auch
aktiviert das sieht man auch am phänomen
der gamification also der
spiegel
modifikation verschiedener bereiche und
zur lebenswelt des spiel ist eine form
der
bestätigung der vergrößerung unserer
freiheit auch die aktivierung
spielen würde ich sagen ist ein
komplexes wirklichkeit verhält muss auch
bereits im schach spielen aber darin
nicht so deutlich sichtbar weil die
regel noch viel zu limitiert sind und
die bewegungsfreiheit einschränkt aber
selbst im schach spielt gibt es wie ich
glaube ein komplexes wirklichkeit
verhältnis
und jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
wie kann sind computerspiele fiktionen
sicherlich insofern wir mit fiktiven
gehalten konfrontiert werden und fiktive
rolle nehmen wir bekommen auch eine
geschichte erzählt in computerspielen
sehr häufig aber wir schreiben die
geschichte auch individuell fort wir
bekommen sie nicht nur vor gesetzt wie
in roman sondern wir können wir stimmen
wie geht die geschichte weiter
wir machen uns in computerspielen die
fiktion zu erhalten bestimmen interaktiv
selbst wie die geschichte aus und weiter
geht wir sind selbst mehr reduziert
teile des computerspiels wir sind nicht
nur äußere beobachter
konsumenten sondern wir selbst und das
computerspiel gehen eine einheit und das
ist ganz entscheidend das ist bei
büchern romanen nicht der fall
darin unterscheiden sich computerspiele
auch von firmen auch wenn wir natürlich
immer sie uns wie ein teil dieses films
finden es ist nur eine simulation
unter spielen ist es nicht nur
simulations- und da werden wir selbst
aktiv im medium der fiktionalität das
ist der wichtige unterschied der sich
auch natürlich ethisch dann fruchtbar
machen lässt
ja computerspiele als simulation muss
natürlich immer sagen das ist denke ich
auch die häufigste auffassung von
computerspielen flugsimulator kampf
simulator wir selbst simulieren in
computerspielen reale und fiktive
handlung
sie existieren die computerspiele des
wegen der spannung von simulation
infektion wir wollen nicht nur
simulieren sondern auch mit der
wirklichkeit auf fiktive weise spielen
wir wollen selbst die geschichte
mitbestimmt wir wollen nicht nur am ende
sagen wollen das war jetzt ja eine
schöne simulation sondern wir wollen ihm
spielen zur realität übergehen an dieser
spannung zwischen bloßer simulation
zwischen kreativer fiktion und zwischen
realisation dieser spannung besteht dass
computerspiele aber auch das
computerspielen als aktivität nicht nur
als passiver modus der konsumieren
und worauf es mir besonders ankommt ist
der aspekt der virtuellen realität wir
simulieren nicht nur beim
computerspielen zurück soll auch
universitäten zum beispiel des online
multiplayer spiele world of warcraft
reißen trotz der sind nicht bloß
simulationen sind realitäten wir haben
es dort mit eigenen währung zu tun wir
haben es mit avataren zu tun hinter
denen sich antritten wirkliche personen
verbergen wir haben es manchmal auch mit
künstlicher intelligenz zu tun die
bevölkern ganz verschiedene entitäten
die virtuelle welt
es entstehen virtuelle kulturen die
nicht mehr angemessen nur durch
simulation fiktion illusion
charakterisiert sind onlinespiel
kulturen sind virtuelle realitäten
virtuelle realität entwickelt sich
sukzessive aus blues simulation fiktion
wenn die regeln des spiels inter
subjektiv geteilt und
institutionalisiert werden das ist ganz
wichtig institutionalisieren und die
intuitive teilung der regeln
dh die ethische bewertung von
computerspielen hängt entscheidend davon
ab ob wir sie als bloße spiel also neue
medien oder konsum medien als bloße
lektion als bloße simulation oder als
virtuelle realität verstehen alle
aspekte sind hier im computerspiel
beinhaltet computerspiele können auch
größtenteils bloße simulations- sein zb
der microsoft flight simulator in ein
kampf simulator das ist stärker eine
simulation da ist noch nicht so viel
virtuelle realität enthalten jetzt kann
aber auch ein adventure sein wird
sondern von monkey island das wäre dann
so ihr eine fiktion aber wir bestimmen
geben darin auch die geschichte
individuell weiter deswegen ist es auch
noch ein bisschen eine simulation und
wenn es dann in richtung multiplayer
spiele geht wo verschiedene akteure
akteure mit dem spiel sind im spiel sind
dann geht es viel stärker in richtung
virtuelle realität wir sehen muss immer
unterscheiden
ja das heißt jetzt stellt sich die frage
inwiefern ist das simulierte töten
simuliert personen computerspiel
moralisch zu nehmen wenn dabei doch
niemand wirklich zu schaden kommt können
wir mit blick auf computerspiele von
fiktiven dass die module aktiven bösen
sprechen und wirklich im gegensatz zum
wirklichen bösen worin könnte das
virtuelle böse bestehen ich hatte schon
gesagt dass virtuelle böse verzieht sich
im virtuellen raum den es verkleinert
und verengt beispiele wären anonyme
falschinformationen mit den andere
informationen reibungslose die infos
wäre verbunden werden und wo menschen
diskreditiert werden auch einfach der
modus der anonymität der im virtuellen
handlungsraum des internets essent ist
ein beispiel hierfür ist das darknet
wenn wir das da geht als einen
virtuellen öffentlichen das internet als
virtuellen öffentlichen handlungsraum
verstehen dann erscheint das tag mit als
ein abgekapseltes schatten raum das
heißt hier verändert sich der raum hier
wird der raum fängt
und das könnte man als einen
unmoralischen haben bezeichnen
da sind jetzt alle virtuellen handlung
geben sagt verzogen werden als solche
bereits moralisch das ist eine frage die
man diskutieren kann künstliche
intelligenz stellt sich ebenso die frage
kann kein böses sein wir halten sie
verhalten sich programmieren nutzerin
und kein miteinander
das phänomen dass die fake ist sehr sehr
zentral das ist natürlich eine
simulation eine täuschend echte
simulation die ganz neue dimensionen
ermöglichen dem man personen visuell
wort in den mund legt die sie noch nicht
gesagt haben natürlich eine simulation
und eine illusion auch also hier
verschmelzen simulation und illusion zu
einer einheit durch die
perfekte wird eine fiktion oder eine
illusion
täuschend echt simuliert
wer direkt die verantwortung für aktion
von kann ihn da die programmier nden
person oder wichtige datenbasis
vertragen
und zum schluss die digitale
unmündigkeit die irgendwie hinter allen
phänomen steht die könnte darin bestehen
dass wir alle informationen im internet
verfahren zu halten als eine mit medien
gläubigkeit einen kritischen medien
haltung wir begreifen die
digitalisierung als eine reihe
technologisches phänomen wir verwenden
die digitalisierung nur zum zweck der
simulation als uhr kampf simulatoren
spielt und das mit der wirklichkeit
verwechselt ich verwende digitalisieren
nur als ein hilfsmittel das
gaming auch zu wenig die
unterschätzendes potenzial
wir verwenden die digitalisierung gesagt
konsum medium das geht natürlich wieder
diese
simulation sec die unterscheide nicht
zwischen simulation in physische
realität also wir glauben wenn wir ein
kampf simulator spielen dann brauchen
wir doch gar nicht mehr kämpfen als es
vielleicht ein schlechtes beispiel wenn
wir ein wenn wir die sims spielen
simcity also wenn wir ein soziallebens
simulieren dann brauchen wir ja gar
nicht mehr im wirklichen leben sozial
interagieren das wäre das beispiel sim
city die frage ist jetzt aber die wie
verhält es sich mit komplexeren
computerspielen die online geschehen war
wer zum beispiel
über davor kraft ist das noch derselbe
wie simcity eine bloße simulation oder
gibt es nicht doch wirkliche neue
soziale formen und das glaube ich ist
der fall als wir eben aktiv world of
warcraft spielt oder andere spiel reisen
trotz der ist nicht nur
von der gesellschaft entfernt sondern
hat ein gesellschafts bezogen auch wenn
er natürlich auch seine probleme hat
aber es ist nicht mehr nur dieser medien
konsum
und wir müssen deswegen streng zwischen
simulation und virtuelle realität
unterscheiden das scheint mir ganz
wichtig zusammen müssen die kreativen
potenziale virtuelle realität gegenüber
der bloßen simulation deutlicher
schätzen werden um die digitale
mündigkeit cent gehen und das betrifft
jetzt eben die frage nach dem ausgang
aus der digitalen mündigkeit
wir sollten das internet nicht nur als
ein bloßes instrument oder medien
verstehen konsum mediums hat als einen
virtuellen anflugs raum
wir sollten die handlung im internet
nicht nur als simulation verstehen seien
eben als virtuelle realitäten für die
wir deswegen auch verantwortung tragen
realität
wir verstehen computerspiele nicht wo
als konsum medien und eine massive
simulation einer scheinwelt so als eine
form der wirklichkeit reflexion das ist
die freiheit die sich darin zeigt und
wir verstehen die digitalisierung nicht
nur als eine uns beherrschende technik
sind als ermöglichung grund von freiheit
inszenierte realität also nicht nur als
simulation das medium wie wir gesehen
haben analoge information und digitale
information dass ein simulations-
verhältnis oder ein reduktions
verhältnis häufig auch diese schönen
bürgern die kontinuierlichen bürgern der
töne werden zu kleinen kästchen gemacht
damit sie auf eine cd passen das wäre
auch eine reduktion sind es sollten
digitalisiert als form unsere
erweiterung der freiheit verstehen
deswegen ist das internet auch nicht nur
ein privilegierter us-konsum medium ist
ein grundbedürfnis nach freiheit welches
alle menschen ein recht haben es hat zu
meiner thesen
im amerika hat auch darauf hingewiesen
dass wir einen öffentlichen gebrauch und
zur vernunft machen sollten haben soll
um der unmündigkeit zu entgehen immanuel
kant hatte das nicht auf die
digitalisierung bezogen wie können wir
jetzt eine digitale vernunft an digital
öffentlichen gebrauchte digitalen von
damit anstreben die digitalisierung
sollte als vernetzung und teilung von
informationen verstanden werden sie
sollte als ermöglichen grund von freier
mitbestimmung und demokratie verstanden
werden als erweiterung unserer freiheit
durch die virtualisierung also mit
kreativität auf simulation auch fiktion
verbunden das sind die form der
virtuellen öffentlichkeit die einen
virtuellen ausgang aus unser digital
unmündigkeit ermöglichen damit danke
mich vielmals für die aufmerksamkeit
über das gesamte semester hinweg ich
würde mich über weitere kommentare
freuen unten auf youtube und freue mich
auf die weitere diskussion